Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
What are caustics?
A caustic is a beautiful phenomenon in nature
where curved surfaces reflect or refract light,
thereby concentrating it to a relatively small
area.
It looks majestic, and it is the favorite
effect of most light transport researchers.
You can witness it around rings, plastic bottles
or when you're underwater just to name a few
examples.
If you have a powerful algorithm at hand that
can simulate many light transport effects
than you can expect to get some caustics forming
in the presence of curved refractive or reflective
surfaces and small light sources.
If you would like to know more about caustics,
I am holding an entire university course at
the Technical University of Vienna, the entirety
of which we have recorded live on video for
you. It is available for everyone free of
charge, if you're interested, check it out,
a link is available in the description box.
Now, the laws that lead to caustics are well
understood, therefore we can not only put
some objects on a table and just enjoy the
imagery of the caustics, but we can turn the
whole thing around: this technique makes it
possible to essentially imagine any kind of
caustic pattern, for instance, this brain
pattern, and it will create the model that
will cast caustics that look exactly like
that. We can thereby design an object by its
caustics.
It also works with sunlight, and you can also
choose different colors for your caustics.
This result with an extremely high fidelity
image of Albert Einstein and his signature
shows that first, a light transport simulation
is run, and then the final solution can be
3D printed. I am always adamantly looking
for research works where we have a simulation
that relates to and tells us something new
about the world around us. This is a beautiful
example of that.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!